[ELECTRONIC MUSIC PLAYING]
JON FAUST: Hi.
And welcome to episode number
206 of the weekly Google Cloud
Platform Podcast.
I'm Jon, and I'm here
with my colleague, Gabi.
Hi Gabi.
How's it going?
GABI FERRARA: Good, Jon.
How are you?
JON FAUST: Pretty good.
Just getting over the
Thanksgiving dinners
and regretting how
much food I ate.
[RECORDING OF PEOPLE LAUGHING]
How was your Thanksgiving?
How was your holidays?
GABI FERRARA: It
was a challenge.
It was nice because
I got to rest.
I got last week off.
And I just got all
the days together.
But I'm tired of the weekend.
I'm tired of resting,
which is weird.
But it's good.
It's a good problem to have.
JON FAUST: Right.
Well, it's not a bad problem
to have a lot of time to rest.
I barely got the chance.
I was driving everywhere
for the holidays.
But glad to hear that you
had a great time resting.
On this episode, we're going
to be talking to developer
advocate and machine
learning engineer Zack Akil
and learn from him what you
can do with ML and creativity,
because he's very
creative when it
comes to building things
from scratch by his hands.
And you'll hear from him how
he takes a lot of inspiration
from the things
he sees around him
to build the really cool demos.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah.
He's very passionate about that.
And it shows.
It's really nice.
JON FAUST: And we're
also going to get
into our question
of the week, which
is how to run cloud functions
in a local environment.
GABI FERRARA: So, yeah,
I'll reply to that later,
but learn how to
use it without--
I know if your
internet's not working,
maybe you need to do that.
JON FAUST: But before that,
let's get into our "Cool Things
of the Week."
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC PLAYING]
GABI FERRARA: We have now a
Stackdriver on our Google Cloud
Code, which is our extension
for Google for visual code.
And you can also
use it on IntelliJ.
And what happens
now, you can see
the logs with your
pseudocode without having
to go to the Google Cloud
Dashboard to see it.
And there is a link there
to see how to enable
that on your favorite ID.
JON FAUST: Pretty sure
any type of extension
that visualizes your
code is so lightweight,
so I think a lot of developers
tend to gravitate towards that.
So, it's pretty cool.
GABI FERRARA: Right!
Good performance usually.
JON FAUST: So, my
cool thing of the week
comes from my recent
travels from KubeCon.
Right before we
did our workshop,
we released version
0.8 of Open Match.
And 0.8 is really focused
around the developer experience.
So, there's a lot
of getting started
guides, a lot of tutorials.
And here you'll see
in our documentation
that they really break down
the most common use cases
and pretty much sample
applications that you
can create using Open Match.
So, if you're interested in
creating a scalable matchmaker,
take a look.
GABI FERRARA: The
other one is, if you're
familiar with what we call
"common type expressions,"
it's a way to do subqueries
and refer in subqueries
without having queries inside
queries inside queries.
The WITH clause with which
you do that, it's now
available on Cloud Spanner.
So, you will be able, Jon,
to create a subquery and then
reference on the next query that
you're creating without having
to copy and paste code--
which is, in most cases,
not a good idea--
and be able to create the var
table and the execution time
to be able to process
that information for you.
So you gain performance and
more visibility on your code.
JON FAUST: Well, that's
going to do it for a "Cool
Things of the Week."
Let's go along and
talk to Zack and see
what he has to say about
AutoML Vision, AutoML
Video, and the cool demos
that he's been working on.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC PLAYING]
And on this episode,
we're going to be talking
to Zack Akil, a very, very
interesting and very good
friend of ours.
Zack, can you tell us about
who you are and what you do?
ZACK AKIL: Yes.
Thank you very much, Jon.
I am a machine learning
engineer and developer advocate
for the Google Cloud Platform.
JON FAUST: And what
specifically do you work on?
ZACK AKIL: So my
role and projects
are all focused around
trying to inspire
developers to implement machine
learning into their projects.
GABI FERRARA: What is a
favorite machine learning tool
that you have on Google Cloud
Platform that you recommend
that you like most?
ZACK AKIL: The products
that I focus around are
all the machine learning
APIs and the machine
learning AutoMLs, which we
like to call the building
blocks of machine learning, that
allow you to gain some power
and value from your data
without necessarily needing
to know all the in-depth
knowledge around machine
learning.
JON FAUST: Awesome.
So, we've mentioned a lot
of the AI and ML tools
and AutoML tools in our like
"Cool Things of the Week"
as they do product updates.
So, can you give
us your definition
of AutoML Vision, AutoML
Video, and best practices,
and maybe what
they're best used for?
ZACK AKIL: The most
common use case
that I always tell people
about is if anyone's ever
used Google Photos
on their phone
or on their Pixel, where
they're able to search
through their own images
based off of tags which they
themselves didn't put
in-- so if you've taken
a picture of the beach, you can
search for the word "beach,"
and it'll find from your own
photos pictures of beaches.
And that's actually
a feature that's
built into the Vision API.
So, you can upload any image,
and it will automatically
annotate it for you with objects
that are inside the image.
And it can even
do things like OCR
or text recognition
within the image.
And we commonly use
that for if people just
have a large storage
of images or videos
to automatically annotate
them to make them easier
to search through or to
gain some insight about what
videos or pictures
people are uploading
into certain surfaces.
GABI FERRARA: That explains why
when we look at Google Photos
and if I search for "winter,"
I can see snow or hoodies,
me with hoodies,
or with a beanie.
Is that correct?
ZACK AKIL: Yeah,
that's the kind of tags
which will appear when you
search those sort of things.
JON FAUST: Awesome.
And that also explains
why it's so easy for me
to find a lot of my game images
that I take screenshots of.
Fully.
And hopefully try to recreate
later on when I'm practicing my
[INAUDIBLE].
ZACK AKIL: Exactly, yeah.
GABI FERRARA: With
AutoML Vision,
what is the most
common scenario?
Is it streaming or other kind
of annotation like AutoML Image?
ZACK AKIL: One of the
main use cases for Video
is in video archive and
search, because a lot
of times with companies
especially, companies
that maybe have their
own storage clients
or are storing a lot of videos--
things like media companies--
they want to store their
videos and search through them
quickly without having to go
through and annotate them.
Common use case that someone
came to me with recently
was with regards
to video editing.
So especially if people are
recording niche video scenarios
where they're
interviewing people,
and they maybe want to get all
the videos where people are
laughing, that's not a feature
that is built into any API
at the moment.
But it is a feature that can
be trained using AutoML Video.
So, if you want a
special type of detection
which detects when people
are laughing, or maybe
special camera
movements, then you
can train your own
AutoML to detect those
so they will automatically
retrieve them when you want to.
JON FAUST: Awesome.
So, you really focus on
AutoML Vision and Video.
So when I first met you,
Zack, maybe earlier this year,
you had a demo
running on your desk
that if you placed an
item in front of a camera,
would tell you whether or not
the actual item was healthy
or not.
And I think the
sample data that you
were using fruits and candy.
So, it seems like you
have a maker's approach
for all of the work that
you do and all of the demos
that you do.
So can you tell us a
little bit about how
you come up with those ideas?
ZACK AKIL: Absolutely.
It all goes back to when
I first got into tech.
And it was I got
an Arduino, which
was this small,
prototyping electronics
board for making projects to
make LED and buttons light up.
And that was my first
intro into programming.
And so when I started
learning using that,
I find it a lot more rewarding
seeing even just a single LED
light up compared to having
some text on the screen move
in a different way.
So since then, I fell
in love with making
physical things happen,
physical hardware demos.
And then after university, I
looked into machine learning.
And it was a lot of really cool
machine learning applications
that were running on
UIs, and desktops,
and exporting CSV files.
And I really wanted to combine
my newfound interest of machine
learning with my old passion
of hardware and electronics.
So now when I come
up with ideas,
I always try to combine
machine learning and embedded
technologies, just because
I think machine learning is
one of the most interesting
new technologies
that people are getting into.
And hardware electronics
is one of the most fun ways
to interact with any
kind of technology.
So I just always try
to combine the two.
GABI FERRARA: And you
also created a demo
that I think you won a
prize or something about it
with a bike in ML?
Can you tell us
about more of that?
ZACK AKIL: Absolutely.
So one of my more
recent projects
is a smart AI-powered
bicycle, which
performs real-time image
classification of what's
happening behind the cyclist.
So as you're cycling
down the road, and say,
a large truck is
approaching from behind,
your handlebars will light up
red to indicate there's danger.
And it will light up
on maybe the right hand
side of your handlebars
if your truck
is on the right-hand side.
And if the truck pulls
from the right to the left,
you'll see a kind
of blob of LEDs move
across your handlebars
to represent the truck.
And I built this
using the Coral Edge
TPU, which is one
of Google's products
for running machine learning
fast on embedded systems.
And that plugs into
a Raspberry Pi.
And I built this, and I built
it onto a physical bike.
And we recently had
an internal hackathon.
And in that hackathon, it
won first prize as just
like a hacky project and
quirky implementation
of machine learning.
But it's actually
a project which
I plan to continue
working on until I
can get a more solid working
concept going and potentially
working with local buy
companies in London
to see if we can get it
onto real bikes for people.
JON FAUST: That's impressive.
I would assume that
you're a cyclist yourself.
And there's probably some
real life inspiration
behind this project.
ZACK AKIL: Oh yeah, absolutely.
There's some horror stories
around being heckled
at on the road by accidentally
pulling in front of people
without seeing
that they're there,
but knowing that I couldn't
really do anything because when
you're cycling in London--
I'm sure it's similar for other
busy cities like New York--
you really can't turn around to
check because you're constantly
having to look forward.
It's just like an
extreme sport is
the way I always classify it.
And the current
technology to help
people be more aware on
the road hasn't really
gotten past mirrors.
They're ugly, and they
don't run machine learning.
So that's why I
came up with this.
JON FAUST: That's awesome.
It's kind of funny, because in
New York you get the opposite.
It's the cyclists who
heckle you when you're
driving throughout the city.
ZACK AKIL: The funny thing is
when I took this, I built this,
and I built a travel
version of this bike,
so like a flat pack
IKEA model of a bicycle
that I would take
around and assemble
on stage to show people.
And I took it down to Sydney,
and I showed it to people.
They all loved it because
in Sydney a similar problem.
But they also notified me of
a specific regional problem
to Australia, which
is for cyclists,
the biggest danger isn't
necessarily trucks or cars,
but actually
territorial birds that
will sweep down on cyclists.
[MAN SCREAMING]
[CRASHING SOUND]
Yeah.
And it's a very, very
common issue in Australia.
And in fact, it's very common
to see cyclists cycle around
with zip ties tied
to their helmets
to create spiky hair to scare
away birds from attacking them.
And, yeah, it's a crazy problem.
And the initial
version of the bike
was just using an
off-the-shelf model
that had traffic detection.
But I was thinking of
making an Australian version
of the bike that has a model
trained in AutoML that has
both traffic and territorial
birds so that it can detect,
oh, there's a car, there's
a car, there's a truck,
and there's a
falcon coming back!
[RECORDING OF PEOPLE LAUGHING]
And what's cool is
with AutoML, it's
actually quite straightforward
because AutoML Noise
supports exporting object
detection models to the Coral
Edge TPU.
GABI FERRARA: Oh!
So, you have it on your
hand without having
to connect to the
internet or relying on 4G?
ZACK AKIL: Exactly, so, yeah.
You can take a model that's
trained in the cloud on AutoML
and just download it to
run locally on a device.
So, you don't need a connection
to the internet for it to work.
GABI FERRARA: And about that--
you also presented that
demo on Cloud Next London.
ZACK AKIL: Yes, yes I did.
GABI FERRARA: How
was the reception?
ZACK AKIL: I always start the
talk by asking, who in the room
is a cyclist?
Fortunately, it seems a lot of
people in tech like cycling,
because it's always the entire
room that raises their hand.
So they seemed to
really like it.
I always also ask, OK,
who cycles in London?
Usually it's about the
same number of people--
if the talk's in
London, of course.
And then I'll follow
that up with, OK,
who would recommend cycling
in London to a family member?
And then all the hands go down.
So everyone's on the
same page as like,
we all cycle in London.
And we all think it's
very, very dangerous.
We wouldn't want
anyone to do it.
I show them the bike.
They seem to really like it.
And then people always
come up afterwards.
Usually actually every
time I've given the talk,
there will be someone
that comes up afterwards
who has an injury that they
got that week from cycling
in London.
And they'd be like, I really
could've used this this week!
So, it really resonates
with a lot of people.
GABI FERRARA: Except the birds.
[BIRDS CAWING]
ZACK AKIL: Yeah.
JON FAUST: That's awesome.
[JON LAUGHING]
And then I do
remember when you were
in New York you were working
on that image classification
matrix or something like that?
ZACK AKIL: Oh, OK.
I was doing a
little side project.
JON FAUST: Yes
ZACK AKIL: And it was
actually my first time
doing image generation where
you can get an AI to generate
new images for you.
And I actually-- I used
TensorFlow.js on my personal
website ZackAkil.com
to generate--
[EVERYONE CHUCKLES]
--to generate the actual title
of the website in real time.
So as you're moving
your mouse around,
it's generating the title.
It's completely useless.
[RECORDING OF PEOPLE LAUGHING]
It doesn't solve any problems.
It's just-- it was
just a bit of fun.
That's how I have fun is
to experiment with new AI.
GABI FERRARA: Beyond the
demos that you build,
I think you have a
lot of interactions
with other developers, too,
being a developer advocate.
Did someone else come to you
with a really cool, interesting
implementation from AutoML
DML APIs beyond that one
that you mentioned
about the laughing one?
Beyond that, do you
have any other examples?
ZACK AKIL: One of the
Next San Franciscos,
and there was a [INAUDIBLE]
talk about giving a video,
and using the Video
Intelligence API,
and the Vision API
automatically bleep out anytime
a person says an acronym.
And immediately afterwards,
someone came up to me
and said that they wanted to
use this kind of technology
using an AutoML Video model to
detect when someone is talking
about a specific subject.
At the time I think it
was "Game of Thrones"
was still pretty hot.
And they wanted to
detect when, say, there
was a video of someone
being interviewed,
and they gave away a spoiler
to "Game of Thrones" and beep
out when they say the spoiler.
ELECTRONIC MALE VOICE:
Hang on a minute.
I thought Ned Stark was
the main character and then
they chopped off [BLEEP]
ZACK AKIL: So, they were going
to use AutoML to build a custom
model to detect that.
So, I thought that
was pretty cool.
GABI FERRARA: They should
did that for trailers, too.
I can't stand--
ZACK AKIL: Oh, yeah.
GABI FERRARA: --when
you go somewhere--
I don't watch trailers
because it spoils it for me.
They reveal everything.
And I want that everywhere.
ZACK AKIL: That
would be perfect.
I feel like it's going crazy
now with the amount of trailers.
They just give away
the whole film.
Perfect use case for an
AutoML Video detection model.
So, automatically
trim down the trailer
to just keep things interesting.
JON FAUST: So Zack, I know
that you're quite the athlete.
I know that you play rugby.
ZACK AKIL: Yes.
JON FAUST: When you
came to visit New York,
you just randomly decided
to go to pick up dodgeball?
ZACK AKIL: I tried to find
rugby, but they didn't have it.
But I settled for dodgeball.
[JON LAUGHING]
JON FAUST: So, do you see
yourself using ML in the sports
and recreational
activities realm?
Or can you tell us
about some demos
that you've done in that space?
ZACK AKIL: Absolutely.
That was my original
inspiration to get
into machine
learning was actually
to build automated camera
equipment for filming
grassroots rugby matches.
Because at school level, I
didn't play rugby initially,
but I recorded the matches.
And then when I started
playing, I really
wanted people to
record my matches.
But nobody wanted to do
it because they didn't
want to stand out there in the
Irish freezing weather holding
a camera steady.
One of my first ever
physical projects
was actually a camera that
would automatically follow
rugby matches and record it.
And I think I gave my first
ever talk at a Pi data
conference about that demo.
And anytime AutoML releases a
new feature, my first examples
of demos are always to do
a sport or sport tracking.
So I'm actually already
talking with some
of the lead coaches of the
Great Britain Tag Rugby
teams about using AutoML Video
tracking and things like that
in combination with drone
footage that's already
been taken of training
sessions to try
to say, track players, and
track their acceleration,
and things like that.
And so, yeah, absolutely.
I expect to see quite a few
sport-related demos, especially
in summertime.
Not so much in the wintertime.
It's too cold.
GABI FERRARA: Except
if it's curling.
You could do something
for curling, too.
ZACK AKIL: Ooh!
That could be nice,
tracking the curl and stuff.
It's not big over here.
It hasn't--
GABI FERRARA: I just-- like
you said, winter sport.
And that one came to my mind.
ZACK AKIL: Winter sport.
GABI FERRARA: So
what is the demo
that you're working on now?
ZACK AKIL: Well, we're just
finishing up all our work
on our most recent
demo, which was
in partnership with the Football
Association here in the UK.
And it was actually the
main demo of the Next London
Conference, which involved
three camera phones--
so their actual Pixel 4 phones--
to record a penalty kick from
a full-siz football, or soccer
net.
And it would upload
all the video footage
to the cloud using
Firestore and analyze them
with video intelligence
and all this stuff,
so that a person would go up,
take three kicks, and then they
would immediately see a
dashboard with the speed
and accuracy along with
the style of their kick,
and get their own player
profile card printed out
for their sticker book.
JON FAUST: Oh, that's awesome.
GABI FERRARA: How long was the
delay from the kick to having
the card?
ZACK AKIL: From kick to
card, the actual printer
itself took a minute.
Getting the kick with
both the actual power
and the style calculations
took about 15 seconds
conservatively.
Sometimes a person would
forget to hit "stop recording,"
and it would take half a minute.
But around 15 seconds
to get all of the data,
continuously analyze,
and then into that image
is about that 15 seconds.
GABI FERRARA: Impressive.
JON FAUST: It's pretty cool.
So, I'm kind of curious,
what ML tools are
you using when it comes
to following trajectories?
Because I would
assume that if you're
bending a ball under
a shot, then there
has to be some way of
tracking the trajectory,
and then hopefully coming up
with a more precise calculation
on, I guess you can
call it, the style.
ZACK AKIL: The way we calculated
the accuracy-- this is probably
the bit of the project that
I was most proud of doing.
Because what we did is we
used AutoML Object Detection,
and we just wanted initially
to track a football moving
across the screen.
And there's already
lots of public data sets
that have footballs and
other sports balls labeled.
And we actually used
the public COCO dataset,
which you can download.
And I actually took that and
dumped it into AutoML Object
Detection, scraping out
just the photos of balls,
and then trained a model that
would track the soccer balls.
And that was the initial model.
It performed all right until
the balls were kicked too fast,
because then they stopped
looking like sharp soccer balls
and were just blurry
smudges across the screen.
And that's when we actually
just collected a bit more data
and labeled it in the AutoML
UI, which is a good use
case for slightly more
customized models,
because the public data set
didn't have blurry soccer
balls.
And after that, it was
performing 99% percent accuracy
on tracking these
fast-moving objects.
And so then what
we did to calculate
accuracy is we just recorded
someone taking a kick,
for each frame, detect
where the ball is.
And then-- I had a bit of
a data science background,
so I played around with
visualizing maybe, OK,
what's the speed of the
ball moving in pixels,
and what's the trajectory of
the ball moving in pixels?
And eventually, I
stumbled across a way
of detecting when the
ball actually made impact
with the goal by
continuously checking
the direction of the
ball that is moving,
and then as soon as the
direction changed suddenly,
that was when it had an
impact with something.
And I would just take that
as the point of impact.
And then we were
also using AutoML
to track the targets that we
had hanging in the goal net.
And then once we knew
the impact of the ball
and the position of
the targets, we just
did a little distance metric
to calculate accuracy.
JON FAUST: Wow.
That's really cool that
you found a work around,
because I know that when
it comes to sports imaging,
they typically use cameras that
have really high refresh rates.
That way you can capture
images really quickly.
But knowing that ML
can solve that issue
with just your standard--
I believe you said you
used Pixel 4 phones, right?
ZACK AKIL: We used
Pixel 4 phones, yeah,
because actually when we were
building the initial prototype,
we were using my
own Pixel 2 phone.
And because most Android phones
have a slow motion capture
of 120 frames minimum, that was
fast enough to capture-- even
people were really
hammering these kicks,
and it was tracking
them, no problem.
JON FAUST: That's
pretty awesome.
ZACK AKIL: That's
using machine learning
to do the heavy lifting
rather than getting
more high-end technology.
I think the original
spec of the demo
we were going to go for these
high-end, high-speed cameras.
But my kind of hackery
nature wouldn't allow it.
I was like, no, I just
want to use a mobile phone
because it's simpler,
and more people
have access to mobile phones.
And rather than having a model
that detects a sharp soccer
ball, we'll just train a model
that detects a blurry one.
It's fine.
JON FAUST: Way to think
of the developer, man.
ZACK AKIL: Yeah.
GABI FERRARA: Did you have
to think that under pressure,
or you had time to do that?
ZACK AKIL: I'm a
notorious procrastinator.
So to answer both
questions, yes.
Yes, I had time, and yes,
it was also under pressure
because I didn't utilize my
time as well as I could have.
JON FAUST: So, I'm
pretty sure you
had to take a couple of shots.
Can you tell us a little
bit about your card?
ZACK AKIL: I did check
my card this morning.
And I remember
exactly the scores.
I got 91 on power.
I got 96 on style and
80 for inaccuracy--
GABI FERRARA: Oh, wow!
ZACK AKIL: --which was average--
[GABI LAUGHS]
ZACK AKIL: --because we
said at bare minimum,
it was impossible to get a score
below 50 on any of the stats.
JON FAUST: That's
super impressive, man.
[JON LAUGHS]
GABI FERRARA: And I'm thinking
everything over 80 was good.
JON FAUST: So, can you tell
us about anything interesting
that developers needing
AutoML for or maybe something
that you have in your
pipeline for demos coming up?
ZACK AKIL: Absolutely.
What I'm looking to do is
using AutoML Video Tracking
to build sports
recognition technology
so that we can track
players on pitches
and work out new
tactics for players.
GABI FERRARA: Is
there anything that we
missed that you would like to
mention before we wrap things
up?
ZACK AKIL: And the only
thing that's currently
on the horizon for me is
using object detection,
exporting to Edge TPUs for
my version 3 of my HTPU bike.
JON FAUST: Where
can people find you?
Are you going to be
traveling anywhere?
Can we expect some
cool demos that you're
going to have open source,
or maybe they can follow you
on your social media?
ZACK AKIL: Absolutely.
So, I am on Twitter @ZackAkil.
Well, you can find
me around London.
I run a London Meetup
group for people
who are looking to get into
any kind of data science
or practical machine learning
called "Central London Data
Science."
And yeah, Twitter and London.
GABI FERRARA: No
conferences coming?
ZACK AKIL: I'm going to
be at [INAUDIBLE] con.
I'll see y'all there.
JON FAUST: Yeah, yeah, for sure.
So, Zack, it's been an
absolute pleasure having you
on this episode.
Really looking forward to seeing
a lot more of your cool demos.
And hopefully we can hang
out a little bit more
when you come back
to New York City.
ZACK AKIL: Absolutely.
GABI FERRARA: Thank you, Zack.
ZACK AKIL: Thank you so much.
It's been a blast.
GABI FERRARA: Thank you,
Zack, for talking to us.
And now we're going to do our
"Question of the Week," Jon.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC PLAYING]
JON FAUST: So, our
question of the week
is how to run cloud functions
in a local environment.
So, Gabi?
GABI FERRARA: The cool thing
about serverless architecture
is that you don't need to
worry about infrastructure.
But sometimes you
want to test something
without deploying first,
which is good practice.
So, you can now use
Google Cloud Functions
for a framework, which it is an
extension for Node.js where you
can create a cloud
function locally,
and you serve your Node.js
application using Express.
And you can hit the URL
that you're just serving
and test your cloud
function locally
without having to
connect necessarily
through the internet.
So it makes your
testing easier, And you
don't have to wait to
deploy all the time that you
do a different
thing on a function.
So I think that's very useful.
JON FAUST: Awesome.
Serverless without the internet.
GABI FERRARA: Well,
it's not the same thing.
Well, it helps with
small case scenarios.
JON FAUST: Right.
So Gabi, where are you going?
Any future travel to wrap
up the end of the year?
GABI FERRARA: So,
no more work travel,
because conference
season's over finally.
I'm going with my
family to Brazil.
So, I'm going to spend
the holidays there.
So, it's going to be a family
meeting, which is nice.
You?
JON FAUST: I just
wrapped up the last
of my conference travel and any
other travel that I'm having.
But what I will
be doing is going
to a bunch of baby showers.
Everybody just decides
they want to have kids now.
So, I will be attending
a couple of baby showers,
one of them being
my twin brother's.
And at the wedding
that we just found out
that they are having a
boy, which they're really
excited about.
GABI FERRARA: Yeah.
You kept that secret from me.
JON FAUST: I definitely did.
But very excited
for them and very
excited for all of my other
friends who are expecting kids.
GABI FERRARA: That's cute.
Thank you all for
listening to this episode.
And we're going to
be back next week.
I will see you later.
JON FAUST: See you.
[ELECTRONIC MUSIC PLAYING]